how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today
we finally after a very very long time
of getting
nothing about the eternals have
something and it's actually really
big we're actually kind of getting our
first look at
the eternals and what they look like now
the eternals release date has now moved
to february 12
of 2021 however if it didn't change we
were supposed to get it in just a few
days but of course it got pushed back
due to the pandemic but luckily it only
got pushed back a few months and today
we're going to look at this leaked photo
of what the eternals as a group
looks like and we also have a new photo
of what icarus looks like
so if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you can stay up to date on all the
latest
mcu news so this first photo as you can
see shows the entire group as a team
as you can see it is in french it says
leicester and it's our first official
look at all the characters in
all of their different costumes now this
is promotional art
official promotional art that has been
leaked so this is pretty much what
they're going to look like the outfits
that they are wearing that's what we're
going to see in the movie
and as you can see they look really
really good we have richard madden right
up front as
icarus and he actually looks very comic
accurate
it's not 100 identical but it's pretty
dang close it looks like the comic
version just with a few upgrades
then if you take a look to the right of
richard madam we see salma hayek's
character
ajak now she's not going to be 100
accurate because of course in the comics
her character is actually a man so
they've done a gender swap here so she's
not going to look like her comic
counterpart but she does
look really really good and she looks
exactly like the leaked photo that we
got of her that was leaked on the back
of a toy box so this is 100
what ajax is going to look like in the
eternals and she is going to be the
so-called
leader of the group to the right of her
we have the one
and only angelina jolie as athena
fina is the warrior of the group and for
the most part she looks pretty comic
accurate as well
since she's the warrior of the group she
wears more armor than the others most of
the time
and as we can see here that is
definitely the case she's definitely
wearing some armor and just like in the
comics it's all
gold and i think angelina jolie was the
perfect casting to play thena in the
eternals
now to the right of angelina jolie
thiena looks to be
barry keegan who is going to be playing
druid now druid is a member of the
eternals but
based off of everything that we know
right now he's actually by the end of
the movie going to be a villain
and the way that he looks right now in
this promotional art kind of looks like
he's playing that part
he's wearing all black and he seems to
have some type of cape or robes on
it's actually fairly comic accurate
because in the comics druid does wear a
cape
and he actually does wear a helmet as
well which we don't see in this photo
now all the way on the right next to
druid it's a little blurry and hard to
make out but it looks like we have
lauren ridloff as
makari now it's kind of hard to make out
what she looks like but again this is
another gender swapped character makari
is originally a man in the eternals
comics and he's actually a fairly
big man in the comics and lauren ridloff
isn't exactly the biggest person but
in the comics makari has an obsession
with speed
he focuses on his body's cosmic energy
to enhance his speed
so speed is the main focus for makari
and you don't really need to be a huge
person to focus on that
but now going all the way to the very
left of this photo we have
sprite sprite is going to be played by
leah mchugh
sprite's body does not age so he
basically always looks like a teenager
this is because he has complete control
over his cosmic energy over his body so
he never ages
bright is the trickster and the jokester
of the group he's very playful
and the fact that he has control over
the cosmic energy of his body basically
makes him immortal and sprite is also
another gender swapped role that we'll
see in the eternals film
now next to sprite we have kumail
nanjiani's character
kingo now kingo is a swordsman and he's
a bollywood star
and typically he dresses kind of like a
samurai now he's not dressed like that
in this photo but there seems to be
somewhat of a theme
on how the eternals are dressed the
clothing that he's wearing looks fairly
similar to icarus's and it doesn't
actually look like it's his
armor but more like his normal clothes
and we actually got another leaked promo
for kingo that shows us a little bit
more detail about his character
now here we get a much more detailed
look at his outfit and it looks really
good and as you can see it looks very
royal it's purple which is the color of
royalty it's got gold on it and it's
very nicely detailed now this promo
seems to be some sort of a game or
coloring book that is coming out for
children
for example on these two pictures that
we have here of kingo at the bottom and
says find the eight differences
but in one part of this book that we're
looking at it says hear
the eternals and it gives a little bit
of a description about them it says the
eternals are a species of immortal
extraterrestrials come from a far away
planet and arrived on earth
thousands of years ago and have been
protecting humans since the night of
time
which is pretty much what we knew about
the eternals already and as most people
know kumail nanjiani got
in insanely good shape to play the role
now next to him it looks like we have
brian tyree henry as
fastos now fastos is an eternal who
doesn't believe in
war he doesn't believe in fighting he
believes in science and he's insanely
smart now what's interesting about this
photo is that he actually
looks blue he is black in the comics but
this definitely looks like he's blue in
this photo so i'm curious to see what
marvel's going to do here with his
character
then next to him we have madongsuk as
gilgamesh
also sometimes known as the forgotten
one now gilgamesh is the powerhouse
eternal he is insanely strong he's the
strongest eternal and he's even been
shown to be stronger than thor
and hercules and as you can see from
this photo he looks
gigantic he looks like a tank his
character looks absolutely
fantastic and last but definitely not
least we have
cersei played by gemma chan now she
looks really good they changed up her
costume a bit because typically she
doesn't wear
that much clothes so marvel studios
probably wanted to cover her up a little
bit more
as you can see it looks like she's going
to be wearing a typical eternals
fashion type of clothing it doesn't look
to be armor but simply what they wear
casually
and jimmy chan looks really really good
as sarzi
now for the final look we also do have
another leaked photo of
richard madden as icarus and this one is
much more detailed
this suit looks very comic accurate with
of course some upgrades to it but for
the most part it is comic accurate and
it's very vibrant it's very bright it's
very regal
he looks like an eternal so this is our
first
look at the eternals it's not exactly
the movie that we were supposed to get
this week but it is nice to get a leaked
photo of what everybody does indeed look
like
now since the movie is coming out in
february that means that we should be
getting a teaser trailer for the movie
relatively soon
in fact many fans are very surprised
that we haven't gotten a teaser trailer
for it already but of course with the
pandemic and everything going on and all
of the projects getting pushed back
there's no surprise that marvel studios
has not released the trailer yet
but it should be coming very soon and it
will most likely come without any notice
marvel studios will most likely just
drop the trailer one day when we're
least expecting it in fact there is a
rumor going around and it is in fact
just a rumor that they could release it
on friday when the movie was supposed to
come out
after all filming and editing for the
eternals has been done for a very long
time now and the pandemic didn't really
affect the eternals that much because
they were pretty much done with
everything before the pandemic hit
and not to mention let's not forget that
at one of the conventions at one of the
comic cons marvel studios did in fact
show footage of the eternals they said
that the footage wasn't entirely
complete that it was still in the
editing process
but this was almost a year ago so the
eternals trailer is definitely already
completed
and it could drop at any time now
including within the next few months
and hey even if we're lucky maybe within
the week but that's just a rumor for now
and we should not expect that to happen
but if i find out anymore i'll
definitely let you know so be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest
mcu news and eternals news let me know
what you think about these leaked photos
for the eternals in the comments down
below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
hmm